uh that is quite the Funko collection
that's amazing that's awesome yeah well
you say that but we moved house and I
had to ship all these across and then
stack them all up um but I'm I'm proud
to have them but sometimes I'll have
serious conversations with people and I
can tell I just staring at the
background thinking what's this guy
doing but yeah thanks for speaking to me
um I have got quite a few questions I
don't know how good they are but um yeah
just watched all the the episodes the
last couple of days and I've really
really enjoyed it um so yeah are you
okay if I just dive straight into them
do it just do it yeah that's great of
course yeah so the second season it
takes a big focus on the Multiverse with
the introduction of angstrom Levy now
multiverses are obviously a big thing in
the comic book industry right now and I
was wondering you know coming into this
if there was anything that you guys
thought how are we going to
differentiate this and and make it
really pop sure yeah I mean well one of
the big things obviously you know
Invincible is based off the comic book
series uh which just celebrated his 20th
anniversary so you know Robert did this
Multiverse thing in his Comics 15 years
ago you know at least uh so you know
we're not we're not hopping on the
bandwagon we're just catching up to
where it happens in our source material
um so I I think our approach too is like
we
never uh we're not approaching it to
make a Multiverse story no one's like
you know it's not like you we've had
multiple iterations of or multiple
iterations of Spider-Man or the flash
those don't exist for invincible so it's
like we don't have that Nostalgia thing
of like oh let's let's see all this
let's see Michael Keaton again that's
amazing you know or let's see all the
different Batman together all the
different Ninja Turtles together um so
that was never Our intention we were
never doing this as a response to any of
those other movies which by the way are
great and I love them all're and they're
awesome uh ours is a little more
character-based you know we have we're
we're actually more telling the story of
angstrom Levy and he happens to have
this power this is his background that
he can travel through Dimensions so we
started with a character first in the
comic books and just focused on that
rather than trying to be like okay this
is our Multiverse version it's not it's
not that we're doing a character story
and just the Multiverse happens to you
know be a part of it I guess definitely
and I actually was so I've been reading
through the comics again um I read them
years ago and I just want to get caught
up with it again and I know you guys
added in stuff like atam Eve with the
shaved in the nightmare timeline and I
was thinking she's sort of like almost a
metaphor for what humanity is going
through like she gets her neck snapped
she's paralyzed but Mark's GNA care for
her and that's kind of what I was
thinking Humanity was like you know
we're very much going to be held in
place by this vomite Invasion we're
going to get cared for because they've
got all the their Sciences but also
there's this horror that's kind of
hanging over it and I just love that
moment seeing the tear almost run down
her face and obvious you guys added that
in um was scripting that out did it was
it just an aha moment of we figured a
way to kind of transform this into one
big gut punch because that's what it
feels like it's just so messed up seeing
it happen oh good I'm glad it I'm glad
it affected you that way because that
was the intention yeah it was to show
you what what vter might occupation
would be like you know and for Eve it's
it's basically it's I love that metaphor
that you brought up that's basically
what it is is that you know we be a lie
but really are you going to call it
living you know with the Vite Empire's
knee on your back and also they're not
just going to Keep Us Alive to Keep Us
Alive they're going to Keep Us Alive to
draw out the resources of our planet to
use it as a staging base to take over
other planets like yeah we'll be alive
but like nobody wants to live like that
you know and neither does Eve in that
scene so that's a way to take something
take a really big idea and make it very
personal and show it on screen happening
in front of your face uh rather than
having to do like you know montages of
the vites arriving with their ships and
stuff like this we try to make it
personal yeah I think that the way you
used the Multiverse as well to just show
kind of both sides on it to show what an
invasion actually looks like and then it
kind of adds more weight to why Mark had
to stop his father from in initiating it
um and just speaking of the Multiverse
in general now this is a I don't need I
don't think you'll confirm this if it's
happening but obviously you worked on
the boys diabolical as well that's under
the Amazon Prime video umbrella I know
Invincible the comics have a lot of
crossovers with other comic book
universes um but is there any way that
you would perhaps tie in you know those
two properties with one thing Amazon I
mean that would be great I mean I know I
think I'm the only person who's worked
on both the boys and Invincible uh
together um I mean that would be wonder
I we don't have anything planned or
anything we can announce right now I
think Roberts talked about it too I know
Evan and Seth have brought it up a bunch
of times so it would be great we here's
the thing we would only do it if it made
sense like we don't want to do it as a
stunt I I don't want to do it as a stunt
you know could we do a CR could you see
omn man and like homelander face off
sure but like where was that where would
that fit in either the boys or in
invincible and make sense and make
narrative sense we don't want to make it
feel like oh it's a stunt to just get
you guys to watch it I mean besides
people do that there's already a great
someone did a great animation of
homelander versus omn man online on
YouTube I think is amazing and hilarious
and great I'm like oh someone already
did it better than we would do it Soh so
that's the thing I don't want to
sacrifice The Narrative and the emotion
of either show to make a crossover where
it doesn't make sense so if if something
came up that made that felt real and
felt good I'm sure we could we would
have a conversation talk about it uh
that hasn't happened yet no I think the
new Mortal Kombat game as well as got
them both in as a bonus character it
does yeah yeah and of course but that's
its own universe that's it own yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah no that's that looks
really cool um now the the main reason I
fell in love with Invincible in the
first place is the arcs that the
characters go on and it starts off is
quite a simple story of like a a hero
origin story and then it
just the break neck twists in it pun
intended are absolutely insane but then
you sort of start to feel like side with
the villains as well which obviously
includes omn man and you have an episode
where obviously Mark goes to to meet his
father again when you're creating these
characters do you feel sympathetic for
them or in the back of your mind are you
thinking oh this guy's terrible but he's
great to write
for well so I mean you know I'm sure
you've heard this term rep but like
nobody thinks they're the bad guy yeah
you know uh characters don't I mean
there are some exceptions but for the
most part omn man thinks he's doing his
duty to his people like he's a sleeper
agent we've had sleeper agents in in
real world history right that's happened
you know people have done terrible
things in the cause of like you know for
their Nation you know throughout history
and throughout Wars so omn man doesn't
think he's a monster he starts to
question whether he is uh I think going
forwards but when he's doing the actions
like initially he thinks this is what he
has to do this is his duty so we try to
treat things realistically that way you
know are there Psychopaths are crazy
people yes obviously but you know for
most of our characters they're doing
what they think is right or what they
have to do so that's where we we start
anyway with most of our most of our
villains you know even angstrom Levy
like he has an idea of what he's trying
to do and he has a reason for doing it
he's not just an insane person being
insane yeah I love that answer um and
obviously you know when you're writing
when you're adapting for a series you
have to kind of move things about a lot
I know the comics happen in different
orders it was there any point where you
were kind of
like I I need to put this bit in this
season even though it comes much later
down the line we need to have this in
because it's such a powerful moment yeah
I mean I think that happened a little
bit more in season one than in season
two we had to do a little more
rearranging in season one uh but
generally what happens like Robert and I
sit down early on in the in the process
and we look at the comics you know and
we look at where we left off and then
kind of trying to find the spot that we
think is a great emotional place to end
a season on we put that in place and
then we start to go through the comics
we start to build out everything in
between the start and the end we trying
to see what feels natural um obviously
we try to follow the books as closely as
we can that's our road map but there are
cases where you want to move stuff
around a little bit for emotional impact
or for plotting impacts I mean obviously
like comic books you know have issues we
have episodes and you know issues end
sometimes in a big moment
you want your television episode to
sometimes end on a big moment but we
only have eight episodes you know eight
hours a comic series like we might cover
20 issues you know in a season or more
or less um so you're just trying to find
natural places that that just the
stories line up with our episodes and
things kind of fall into place it's a
really organic process uh and it changes
like you know we we cover a different
amount of episodes than we did in season
one and uh that's going to change again
for season three and I would you know
assume beyond beyond it's just like some
Seasons want to run a little quicker
through the books some want to run a
little slower it's just we just figure
that out as we sit down and start to do
it yeah and I think especially in
episode one you can see where you really
added character to how Mark feels like
my my parents got divorced and that's
kind of what I saw his journey in that
first episode almost being like like I
know in the books it kind of he doesn't
get necessarily get over it quickly but
he adjusts into this new life and is
kind of thrown into it whereas yeah you
really see the emotion that comes from
it and even him you know having the high
moment at the end where it almost feels
like he's on top and then bumping into
the immortal and it kind of just brings
him back down I really related to that
and just felt like that they're doing
something with a character that I never
even really placed on this situation but
I can definitely relate to it myself um
so yeah I absolutely loved all that
stuff oh thank you now yeah no genuinely
really really took me away um and just
in general right one this is probably
going to be my last question um but I've
always just wondered this so J JK
Simmons he played Jay Jonah Jameson now
omn man looks like J Jonah Jameson was
there ever a point where you like we'll
have to get him to to play omn man you
know what the one of the reasons that we
looked at him early on and want wanted
him for the role was I I saw him in
Whiplash yeah and he scared the out
of me in Whiplash and but also starts
the movie being like kind of this nice
guy and he's able to flip between being
a normal person like a normal dad and
the most terrifying person ever on film
uh and that is omn man we knew omn man
was going to have to make that change he
was going to start off being this great
dad but also have these enormously Dark
Places he would go to in these really
terrifying moments you know I always
think of vmit as being like a great
white shark like you're in the water and
there's great white shark swimming
around and if it chooses to kill you
that that's just what's going to happen
so it's this terrifying moment of just
not knowing what he's going to do and
seeing JK and
Whiplash uh I was like we need to look
at him like this is this is the kind of
change the dichotomy that we need for
this character so yeah so that was one
of the reasons we uh we went with JK and
looked at him early of I mean he's an
incredible actor a hundred times over
Jonah Jameson looks like omn man yeah
yeah I have to get this right yeah I
mean like they yeah there's a yeah they
kind of look the same I guess but
honestly that's honestly that's not cast
him I wish it was we should just cast
every character just looks like the
actor who looks the most like the
character yeah no it was it was really
really enjoyed it and again just with
the whole divorce metaphor seeing omn
man move onto his new life and then
Mark's kind of got to accept that and
he's got a a new brother and stuff yeah
it just made me appreciate the The
Source material so much more and um I
really really enjoy those those four
episodes I got to see so thanks so much
oh thank you no thank you like we
appreciate I appreciate the time you
spend watching the show and talking
about it because that helps us get an
audience and helps us make get to make
more of the show which is really all we
want to do so yeah yeah no really really
good genuinely thank you yeah thanks for
speaking to me as well no I appreciate
it yeah really nice to meet you Paul
hopefully we'll talk to you again maybe
for the back of season two yeah no I'm
down 100% yeah thanks a lot